there was let's say sexual activity
early in every relationship right and
that sexual activity created
a chemical bond of this feels good and
this great connection and
and there was no conversation about
values or vision or lifestyle
we're having fun this is a great time
we're experiencing life together and
we've got this
chemical bond this time i said listen
there's there's not gonna be any of that
i mean my friends are like in shock
especially my guy friends
i'm gonna get vulnerable here but it's
almost three months i spent 40 nights
next to her without without that
activity going on and um
talk about self-discipline for me as
someone who's driven by you know who
wants that a lot sure i was just like
it's not worth it it's not worth it
until i find out like
where this is going
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast i
am so excited to have this guest on the
show today he's a friend i have
interviewed him before
uh which gosh he's going to be the first
person i've interviewed twice so that's
because he's so amazing and it's lewis
howes
he is a new york times best-selling
author uh he has two books the most
recent one is called the mask of
masculinity we talked a little bit about
the fact that he's writing another book
which is going to be awesome so we start
off with talking about that uh he's also
he also has an amazing and huge podcast
called the school of greatness it's
actually because of being on his podcast
and two others when i was promoting my
own book years ago that i thought wow
that was really fun i think i i really
like doing these podcasts and then it
led to doing my own so
lewis is an incredible human being
really is like kind of a man of service
and just you know that was one of the
things we talked about is just how you
know what is his role you know being a
voice and a leader and you know he
shares what he wants to be for people
and you know what he wants to help men
step into which is really just a place
of vulnerability and being honest we
just talked about the dynamics of
relationships that incredible lesson of
uh standing up for yourself and and not
in a negative way but just knowing who
you are and creating boundaries and
being really clear about that and just
what that brings into your life you know
transparency is a beautiful thing when
it's done with love and and you know
with your inner inner child as we talked
about a lot in in mind because when
we're out of alignment with that is when
the problems start and our compromises
turn into resentment and and it's a
spiral uh into a place that's no no no
where you want to be so
just super vulnerable guy super super
kind and we had a really really great
conversation man i'm just i'm inspired
by him and i think you will be too enjoy
the episode how are you i'm good i miss
your face oh miss your face mr mr hugs
even though i've only hung out with you
a few times but i feel like we give good
hugs oh yeah
when when i said who i was interviewing
today my boyfriend was like i would like
to go to dinner with him he's like yeah
i've heard he's a guy and i'm like he is
a great guy i asked if he wanted to talk
about anything today or promote anything
and he was like nope just in service
just happy to do it and i'm like you
just are that good of a guy i appreciate
it yeah well when i have a book or
something then i'll make sure to to
promote it i'll i'll hit you back up and
say hey let's promote the book
done not a problem how long has it been
since your last book the mask of
masculinity was your second book right
four years ago yeah four years ago so
i'm actually right now in talks with
coming out the book the end of next year
yeah so i'm working on that right now
end of next year means you bet you're
gonna have to get started i'm just
getting started in the last few weeks
yeah oh really so it's either going to
be end of next year or maybe january at
the latest we're still figuring out
when it's going to come out but i'm i
mean i've been researching it in my mind
for years working on this but now it's
like okay let's make it happen
well
it's about the greatness mindset and
it's about eliminating self-doubt i
think self-doubt is the biggest killer
of dreams
i think there are three main fears that
we as human beings
have the fear of failure which a lot of
people have they're afraid to fail and
so they don't take action on what they
want or their goals or their dreams
because of that that insecurity or fear
around
what if i fail
the second big i never had that as an
athlete i don't think you ever had that
because as athletes we are trained well
you got to learn you got to make
mistakes every day to learn to get
better
to help you become successful and
accomplish your goals so i knew failure
was a part of the journey i'm like
practicing
to accomplish success and there's a
great
meme online i'm going to abbreviate what
the meme says because i can't remember
specifically
but there's a meme of a photo of a baby
walking or like trying to walk
and the quote or the meme says something
like
you know
children fall a thousand times before
they learn to walk
and never does the child think maybe
this walking thing isn't for me
i think i've seen that you know i mean
it's like he doesn't the child doesn't
think yeah i fell 20 times i scratched
my face i you know my elbows bleeding i
hit the back of my head maybe i should
just crawl the rest of my life because i
keep failing
and um i think you know once
the other two fears come and apply
people are just afraid of failure the
second
fear which i never understood personally
because
i always wanted to accomplish my goals
was the fear of success
and when i when i speak or when i talk
to people when i ask them are you more
afraid of failure or success i'm always
surprised a lot of people say that
they're afraid of success
and again this didn't make sense to me
because i wanted to achieve i wanted to
succeed that's what i was going after
and
and i would ask people like why are you
afraid of success and they would say
something like well the the pressure you
know the pressure that comes with
success the weight you have to carry
the idea that you have to live up to
something now like i've accomplished
this i have to keep doing this otherwise
then i'm a failure
um or
if i go and pursue my dreams
you know my family won't go with me or
they'll they'll kind of outcast me which
or my friends my peers you know i'll be
leaving the tribe the community
and i'm afraid to kind of lose my
friendships and be more alone or
independent so that fear of success is
strong for people those were never my
fears
my fear was something else and it's the
third
uh the third fear which i think
a lot of people have as well which is
the fear of judgment
and
and criticism and other people's
opinions and
um i was never afraid of the failure
side because i knew as an athlete i
needed to make mistakes in order to
improve to get better to achieve i
always wanted to be successful so that
was not a fear of mine the pressure of
when i succeeded it was more just like
people's opinions of me or people
doubting me are people
criticizing me and judging me oh man i
lived that
right and so
at the core
you know usually someone has one of
those or maybe all those i'm the first
one right fair failure yep
yeah and so from and at the at the
center
so if you made it like a three-circle
venn diagram at the center
of
our fears is i'm not enough of course
that was totally my problem that is
totally my problem i yes it's a dad
wound yes exactly and i expressed it in
the mom
yeah exactly and then the inner child is
always in pain and suffering so
i literally this has been this has been
a year of therapy for me i've done
therapy
every two weeks the entire year since
january
i am with you i had two therapists at
one point that i talked to every week
yeah the first six months was like every
week like i was in couples therapy for
the first like five and a half months i
guess at least
it was every week it was like five seven
hours at a time on a day like we'd go on
saturdays and do it together oh god and
it was it was so intense
but as an athlete
we uh we'll do whatever it takes you
know we're like i'm gonna keep trying
i'm gonna keep going whatever it takes
leave no regrets you know so
that was my mindset not even a single
letter
exactly yeah and i
and i said after
after i realized that in the previous
relationship that our our visions
weren't aligned and we weren't
uh a great match values and vision wise
i said you know what i'm going to keep
doing this i'm going to do this for the
rest of the year for myself
and see what that does for me and i have
this photo i don't know if you'll have
if this is a practice that one of your
therapists ever do with you
i have this photo i have this photo on
my phone can you guess what this is can
you guess what this photo is that i've
had since
january i don't know maybe your inner
child see you as a kid
it's me as a kid i love you guys it's
just uh me and my dogs
there you go yes so this is a photo i've
had
since since january
and my uh
and my therapist was like
listening and i said why do i keep
choosing specific types of relationships
not that these people are bad and wrong
not that you know
nothing just not the right match for me
right and there was um
i kept doing it because i kept
abandoning myself i kept abandoning
myself on my values and my vision to
create peace and make someone else happy
as opposed to
being peace and healing that i am not
enough inner child wounds
to creating boundaries
and then creating from a place of
standards and agreements not i'm
constantly having my agreements broken
by a partner
and giving in to try to make them happy
to create peace yeah and so it's been an
incredible year
of
reflection of getting feedback of
healing that and
and really diving back into again to
those three fears that a lot of people
have is
the core of any of those fears is i'm
not enough i'm not pretty enough not
talented enough smart enough whatever it
might be
and i think when when we learn to fully
accept
and heal what we've been through and
accept where we're at right now
there's a foundation that we can move
forward with a mindset we can move
forward with
that as a place of creation and pursuing
our uniqueness and our gifts in the
world and and putting ourselves out
there in a way that no matter we win or
lose people love us or hate us we do it
from a place of joy and a place of peace
because there's inner acceptance
when i had i'm not sure did you know
kobe pretty well or did you interview
him
i only met him once i i forced my way
into an introduction at the espy's one
time to say hi and that's kind of my my
my publicist at the time was the i mean
like he was a humongous fan and so i i
got him to say hi like wanted to
introduce i met i introduced myself so
that i could introduce him um and uh
that's it though i didn't know him yeah
i when i when i interviewed him i only
met him for you know an hour and um so
i'm not like i'm close with him or was
it close with him but
when i interviewed him
he said
when he was i can't remember if he was
12 or 13 but when he was like 12 or 13
he was playing basketball in a summer
league
and he didn't score one point he said
the entire summer it was like two or
three months he didn't score once
and it was somewhere around 10 11 12 or
something like that
and
i said what made you want to come back
and like after you failed miserably the
whole summer why did you want to come
back and play basketball again like the
next year or whatever
and he said i'm paraphrasing this but he
said
that my father told me that he's gonna
love me no matter what he's like i don't
care if you
score all the points or if you score no
points i'm gonna love you no matter what
and he said that gave him permission to
pursue something without one of those
fears without the fear of failure
without the fear of success and the fear
of judgment
and i think
when we can learn to
love our own selves no matter what not
needing that from someone else or you
know whether it was your father or your
siblings or whatever it may be
for me it was peers you know being
judged by peers when i can when we can
learn to accept ourselves for who we are
and create from that space of inner love
and inner peace which is hard to do it's
hard to get there
that's when i feel like we can create
some amazing things in the world so
that's the premise of the book the
greatness mindset that's really cool
that's going to be a really powerful
book as they all are from you
because it comes from your own
experiences you know like when you're
speaking from pure experience there's
there's depth there's emotion connected
to it there's truth and i think that
truth holds a frequency and so there's
an energy and a frequency within the
book and the writing that's that's
undeniable because it's not just a bunch
of words that you know we've heard a
million times written in a spiritual
book or written in like a self-help book
or a you know go get em kind of book
it's like your life on come to life
alive on the pages
um
i i don't know how come i mean you're a
pretty open guy but you we can we could
push the brakes anytime but i'm curious
because i think that this this idea that
i mean
i love that we're talking about
self-help and about looking in the self
and the inner child and the way that
things relate to our childhood and you
know it's something that i've been
working through for years now and i know
you've been working on for even longer
and you know i think giving some
examples and just
talking through how that goes because
there's i feel like there's so much
anxiety and so much stress in the world
and especially nowadays and it's like
maybe we can just sort of shed some
light from our own experiences just how
that looks and how that can show up in
our life and we can maybe learn how to
cope better because that inner peace
comes from making peace with those
things yourself
so like what was sort of the first
big hurdle that you came across or got
over
in therapy and and with the process of
therapy because sometimes my
breakthroughs came on my own but
maybe the impetus was a was it was a
therapy prompt or something to do with
it so like do you remember what the kind
of first thing was where you were like
i don't know
why i'm crying yeah yeah exactly i i
started my i would say i started my
healing journey eight years ago
yeah and where i started doing
therapeutic experiences workshops
therapies
that allowed me to start heal certain
parts of of the met what joe dispenza
says the memories of the past because
these are memories that we
either amplify or diminish in our in our
thought and our memory so there's an
event that occurs
we have a memory of the event and we
either
make it 20 times great more grandiose
than it was which is probably what i do
uh you know have done and you know i
went through this and this is how it was
but was it really how it was or is that
how our memory is
or we diminish certain things you know i
really didn't do this well or that
whatever it might be
and so for many years i've been doing
therapeutic experiences
um and i talked about this publicly
where
at the beginning it was healing the the
sexual abuse that i faced when i was a
kid which was really blocked inside of
my
body for 25 years i never told anyone
and that took
a couple of years of unwinding and
surrendering to and letting go and i
thought i'd done all the work you know
okay isn't it always the case yeah then
and then i was like every couple years
i'm like oh wait why am i still like
struggling with something so level new
devil exactly and i
and this time i was realizing that
sure i became a lot less reactive and
triggered in the real world
uh because i had healed something where
there had been abuse right i'd heal
something where there was a trauma so i
felt a lot less reactive whereas before
i turned 30 and started doing this work
i was very triggered and reactive person
i was a fun loving guy but when i felt
under attack
like mentally and emotionally i would
react what triggered you
i mean
it was always the feeling of when
someone i when i felt someone was trying
to take advantage or abuse me it's like
abuse my generosity take advantage of me
use me for something
without like a good intention of just
like hey we're friends but they're
always trying to angle something or
abuse or
you know if it felt like that i'd be
felt triggered and i didn't plays into
the sexual abuse right sort of the
parallel later yeah being taken
advantage of when i was you know
five-year-old
and so
but i i still struggled in all my
intimate relationships like i was better
in business and friendships in the world
but still struggling in intimate
relationships
and i didn't know why and i kept
choosing
relationships again
all wonderful individuals i have nothing
better to say about them it's all my
responsibility of choosing
and abandoning certain things about my
vision
to make something try to work
and there was a moment in therapy
earlier in the year
where this has been a pattern in the
last decade from all the all the
relationships i've been in so this was
an earlier in the year this year yes yes
and there was a there was a pattern in
the last
probably every relationship i've been in
but i'm thinking of the last 10 12 years
of the the different intimate
relationships i've been in
there would always come to a point where
i'd feel a sense of like tightness and
pressure in my chest in every
relationship
and i feel more and more stress and
tightness and almost like kind of heart
palpitations at times
and this kind of like
underlying feeling of
trappedness and stress and and like
anxiety in my chest and always in my
chest and eventually go to my throat
and i didn't you know it's just kind of
like it wouldn't happen right away it
was like six to eight months in every
relationship i started to feel this and
then i would say okay i'm an athlete
this is not going to fail i'm going to
make this work so
what can we what can i do how can i be
better how can i make you happy how can
i improve this relationship
let's go to therapy let's do this
together and i always thought this was
weird i always thought this was weird
that i would suggest therapy to every
past relationship and say i really want
to do therapy because i care about you i
care about us i love you i want to make
this work and something's not feeling
right
and they would all say no they don't
want therapy and i was like what i feel
like every woman would die if they're
die
right
yes and i was like come on like
this makes no sense to me you're like
the one woman and i kept choosing the
one woman that didn't want therapy and i
was like what
and um
anyways i realized i was i was dating
patterns and um again nothing wrong or
bad about it but it was it was a pattern
and this
past
experience was the same thing for a year
i was like i really wanted to do therapy
i think it'd be important i remember
saying i would love for us to do therapy
in the beginning when things are good so
we just continue to like get things
cleared and we grow in a vision together
yeah
that wasn't the case and then
after a year of it ghana being up and
down right some good moments but then a
lot of like down moments
i remember was just like we can't do
this anymore like this isn't going to
last we either need some support
or i don't know what we're going to do
because we're it's too up and down for
me it's not sustainable
and
finally you know after a year of asking
for this we finally were able to make
the therapy happen and
it was extremely profound for me
because it got me to have
someone with a different perspective see
the whole picture and it got me to talk
about these things and step back and be
like wow why why am i choosing to stay
in this why is keeping me motivated to
stay in this
and how can i take full responsibility
for why it's turning out this way
and there was a moment in therapy where
literally like the pain in my chest
came together and kind of disintegrated
into a ball into like peace and freedom
and like just disintegrated
and it was the weirdest thing
that i've ever felt because it felt
physical transformation in a moment i
had just like this awareness moment i
always used to feel like
i was trapped like i needed to make it
work and i could not end the
relationship there was no
i was not willing to end the
relationship so i would just stay in it
and keep trying to make someone else
happy
as opposed to
not abandon myself so what i realized is
that i was abandoning my inner child the
needs that i had over and over again for
someone else and i thought it was
unselfishness
as opposed to coming together into a
partnership with
here's who i am here's who you are do
you accept who i am right now and do i
accept who you are right now
and the partners that i was choosing to
be with never fully accepted me they
wanted me to change constantly and i
chose those relationships so i can't
blame them uh you know i don't i take
responsibility for staying in a
relationship where people wanted to
change me consistently
and i just chose that i want to keep the
peace so i'm going to do whatever it
takes to make this person happy
but they were never happy no matter how
much i changed and how much i did they'd
always get upset at something
and that's when i realized like i don't
need to stay in relationships i can end
it and i'm not a bad person because i
always thought like if i end this i'm a
bad guy
i'm gonna hurt someone and you know what
if they say something bad about me and
then
judgment
like the third thing of this year that's
judgment
and then i was just like
that was so held back by that fear of
well
what about the what if people think that
what if they say something that's not
true that i don't have control over
and then
people think i'm a bad guy or whatever
or my reputation whatever
and then i just got to a point where i
was like none of this pain is worth
anyone's opinion about me anymore
and
i'd rather feel free
and let people think whatever they want
to think
then be stuck and trapped in this
emotional um relationship that i'm
choosing to put myself into no one's
forcing me yeah and that
awareness
just gave me the sense of like peace
that i was like you know there's no
amount of abandoning myself that is
worth
worth it no matter what the consequences
are so it's been up wow so there's
constant there's constant learnings of a
lesson yeah so was that this is the part
i'm curious about can you can you see
how that was a dynamic in your
uh familial situation
did you play the role because like as an
example if i'm gonna share to be
vulnerable and help people understand
like my wound was not being good enough
because i was always pushed by my dad so
like i found part partners that would
push me
and that i wasn't good enough for and
then what i didn't realize is i would
act like my mom and abandon myself
emotionally that's the part that came
later that i didn't realize i was doing
um and so can you see the pattern and
how that played out in your your
parental situation 100
it's 100 i mean
it's very uh it's very interesting to
look back and
you know parent dynamics are
beautiful and messy at the same time oh
yeah i mean we love them but it doesn't
exactly i always try and say it's like
god every parent is going to give their
kids something because you're going to
love them too much you're too little
it's just the way it goes so like get
over it it doesn't matter it's it's just
it's the human experience so what i what
i realized this year if i look back
my mom always wanted to keep the peace
so she would abandon herself no matter
what was happening she would
stay calm and relax she would
give in to whatever to kind of make my
father like happy and my father had more
let's say
i don't know if i would
it's it's interesting because he had a
massive transformation at one point in
his life and completely changed
after i turned 13. but before 13
he was a lot more challenging to be
around let's say and very loving like
would
put me to bed every night and kiss me
and hug me and affectionate but it was
just like
he had some narcissistic traits i don't
know if he was like
full-on but he had some narcissistic
traits
and i think my mom
would do whatever to keep the peace
and so as i look back at it i have
chosen to date
into women with
i would say narcissistic traits and for
whatever reason i was lured in
by
something something hooked me in and
learn the lesson that's what you were
hooked in by but i kept i mean i kept
repeating it over and over and over i
get it we all do yeah yeah
and so and then i took on the role of my
and my dad was extremely charismatic and
amazing and smart and intelligent and
you know a great guy a lot of
narcissists are i know exactly i just i
just had uh dr romney oh god i
interviewed her too she's incredible it
just came out last week and i've been i
literally didn't even know what
narcissism was until like a month ago oh
my god really when i've been studying
this now i'm just like seeing all these
patterns from previous relationships oh
yeah and i asked her and i go
i go
because i was having so many aha moments
in the interview with her and i was just
like yeah i feel like
everything you're saying a narcissist i
feel like this is certain things that i
went through
and i said why do i why do you think
that i might have been someone attracted
to those traits whether they were
full-on or spectrum or a little bit
whatever
and we probably all have some little
narcissism somewhere
but i said why do you think i was
attracted to this scene she said
athletes have a high tendency to either
be extreme narcissists
or be
uh attracted to narcissists and i said
why
and she said because you have a do
whatever it takes mentality right you
you'll you'll fight to the end you'll do
whatever and i was like that's what i
did i was like working on therapy for my
i was like i'll stay in this for years
to try to make it work
as opposed to
quitting right the idea of quitting and
ending the relationship that was my
biggest fear ending a relationship where
there was connection where there was
love there was intimacy where there was
fun times and um
so anyways i digress because i was
fascinated by what i'm learning from
that
and i also think there's another part of
it i also think that there's another
little part of it where we're also
trying to correct the original wound
absolutely and so we think we attract
these partners because we think deep
down like we can correct the original
we can heal it we can fix exactly if i
can fix this one person it means it
wasn't me it means that i can change
them it means that it doesn't this
doesn't need to be the the pattern and
the reality in the way that it was but
the problem is is that we never can and
so the pattern just repeats itself until
we you know
she's yeah and dr uh romney said i go
will the narcissists ever change
they won't change and i go so what do
you do
if you're in a relationship with one and
she's like you cannot change them you
either need to leave or you need to have
radical acceptance knowing that your
feelings will just be shouted into an
abyss and you won't have anyone to be
able to connect with on that and i go
that seems like a miserable existence
isn't it the most fascinating
human dynamic ever and the thing is
about narcissists is that they all i'm
i'm an expert now um they all like i
mean truly like i haven't you've watched
every video of it every dot every video
i mean i
i knew ever i knew basically everything
that she was saying in the interview
because i had watched so many hours of
her and everybody so what i wanted her
on for was to share the information um
because she's an expert you know she's
great but um
but but the the fascinating thing i find
in in psychology is that they all fit
into the same profile and they don't
even know they're narcissists and it's
like crazy
it makes me think they're zeros and ones
well that's why she said i go
i go
you know what give me some of the
examples of what a narcissist might be
she's like well a narcissist well she
said it's extremely hard to diagnose a
narcissist like as narcissistic
personality disorder
because it takes multiple sessions in
therapy in order to be able to get to a
point of a diagnosis
and she goes
very rarely will you see a narcissist go
to therapy
and i go oh
none of my ex-girlfriend i always wanted
to go and none of them wanted to go i
was like that's interesting not saying
that they were full-on narcissists or
whatever but
it's interesting that there's a
resistance to feedback there's a
resistance to looking within the mirror
and saying
you know what maybe i do have some
challenges that i could like to take
ownership on and improve on and you know
i'm not perfect
and um so anyways it was it's been a
fascinating month just from that
understanding but for me the dynamic
goes back to yeah i think i always try
attracted women without even being aware
of it yeah that once it got to a point
of oh
we're not aligned on our values and our
vision not that it's right or wrong
we're just not aligned
i would say well
well we've created this incredible
dynamic and connection and had these fun
times so i'm just going to do whatever
it takes to make you happy to make this
work
and that was all that was my lesson to
learn how to walk away when something
wasn't in alignment with my higher self
and so this has been a profound year
of
continued healing of the you know my
little louis who
i abandoned for 30 plus years
to create peace
to try to make someone happy with who i
was and change myself to please them the
way i watched my mom do that with my dad
i cried so much from my inner child like
i would literally like hug myself i did
the same i did this
did you hug your i didn't actually i did
an exercise one time that made me weep
like a child where
i was laying i first did wim hof
and started breathing and like just
channeling it and moving the energy
throughout my body
and then i was meditating afterwards and
i did an ex exercise where i was laying
down
and
i would see my five-year-old self that
was sexually abused
and i was holding my five-year-old self
and then i had a moment where i was
having a conversation
with my five-year-old self saying
i got you like we're here now
and then i like immersed i like put him
into me i was like hugging myself just
like that it was
crazy crazy experience oh man wow i i
feel like this i remember doing
something very similar and it was like i
think i even made a post about it it was
like i've got you like i i always have
it's like oh my god the inner self like
i've got you and i always have it's like
even through the [ __ ] you're like and i
always have that's why you're here now
and it's like the the the the true self
i just got done talking to kimberly
snyder she has a new book coming out and
you know there's a lot of talk about the
true self and
you know the true self is so subtle the
inner child the higher self whatever you
want to call it um it's so subtle and so
quiet and it's like my when i looked at
my inner child when it fir when i first
started this practice and this dynamic
and learning my inner child was
literally stuck in the top of a top of a
like top top of a building in a dome
that was concrete and there was like a
tiny little window hole out it and no
words then then her child came down and
was in the bottom of this like structure
and was like at the door but still
wouldn't say anything and it was like
this process of letting the inner child
emerge and like i never gave it a voice
i never paid attention to it i should
have put a picture of my inner my little
self on my phone too it's still time to
do it yeah true that's true
sorry sorry ella um but as my dog lays
next to me um but but it's like the
practice of of getting in touch with
that voice and that that energy and that
message and that
truth
it's so subtle because the ego is so
associated with what's happening right
now and it's it's not like the ego the
ego is generally a little bit of a
nemesis but the but the but that's just
because it's short-sighted like all it's
trying to do is mitigate against against
pain and so
you know the pain of being rejected it
goes oh that's okay we'll adapt right
the ego goes no no that's fine that's
why i will just adapt and like you know
what you need to learn how to do is is
balance them out give the inner child
give your higher self a voice and bring
the ego down and allow it to have some
pain but like the ego doesn't want to
ever be in pain and you know it's it's
it's just this dynamic that we go
through in life and so you know that
inner child stuff is really really
powerful did your um
did your uh
your child have anything that um
he wanted to say i'm guessing it's a he
yeah um
let me think back to that moment i mean
i think he was just really scared and
uncertain and unsure and felt very alone
that's what minor child felt
and so when i was having a conversation
it sounds weird to saying when i was
having a conversation with my inner
child but
when i was having a conversation i just
said you're not alone i'm here you're
safe i'm protecting you i got your back
we're in this together
look how far we've come
you know and that conversation was
really powerful for
my five-year-old psychological self to
hear
because i think um
you know as joe dispenza says that the
memory of the past we're stuck in this
old memory
and we're bringing the past pain to the
present
and we're never able to create a
peaceful
powerful authentic future
if we're still living in the memory of a
painful past
as opposed to healing
having wisdom not saying it was a fun or
cool thing that you experienced but
having wisdom around it and being able
to make more conscious authentic
decisions from that wisdom of peace
and acceptance again going back to i am
enough
at the being at the core not i am not
enough yeah and i was just interviewing
dr david perlmutter yesterday and he was
saying that um i mean i think a lot of
neuroscientists talk about this but
there's two parts of the brain he said
the fear-based part of the brain which i
believe is called the amygdala and then
the pre prefrontal cortex which is the
future thinking compassionate part of
the brain
and if we have a memory of the past
that is constantly
scary and shameful and insecure or
hurtful
then whenever we
experience a moment or an event
that triggers that pain
we go into the part of our brain which
is the fear-based part the immediate
part
which
it's
nearly impossible to react from a
compassionate calm place when that part
of the brain is triggered
and so healing those traumatic parts of
the past or whatever we have
allows us to then when the event occurs
maybe it still startles us and maybe
there's some like
frustration or sadness or anger but
we're able to get back to a calm
part of the brain the prefrontal cortex
to allow us to choose
it's like the adult in the room as
opposed to child in the room reactive
and we're able to make an adult decision
as opposed to a painful child decision i
think
it's fascinating when we learn when i
keep learning about this stuff and i'm
like it's funny
i love psychology and you know it's like
you know people like
bruce lipton and guys like that that
study this sort of stuff these
scientists but you know i've never had
bruce on is he good i i haven't but he's
booked finally oh yeah so i think he's
booked for january or february um
he's really excited he talks about
epigenetics a ton and just oh my god i
love that um but but one of the one of
the things that he says many times is
just how
your uh subconscious programming is
is established which is 95 of how you
operate in the day established from the
last trimester through the first sort of
six
six seven eight years at the most six
seven years of your life and so
it's not a shock that your inner child's
five it's you know most of the time it
is at that age because that's when those
subconscious programs that's why we
can't see it either and that's the sort
of fascinating experience of being human
is that it takes since we can't see
ourself it takes the outside world to
reflect it to us through patterns
through triggers in relationships same
relationships yeah
and the relationship is totally the most
like the the biggest one where we get
our lessons because it's so emotional
for us right like we can kind of step
aside from mom and dad sometimes you
know we go they live there we live here
but especially when you're in a
partnership with someone like that's
where it's in your face every day and
that's where the biggest he and it's
like i don't know if you've noticed this
but
when i always think to myself okay like
growing is painful
growing pains like there's always always
going to be painful and i think to
myself but the next time i have a growth
spurt it's not going to be so bad like
i'm ready for it and then it comes and
it's just as shitty as the last
right right and i'm like why is it so
and i'm like at least i keep coming back
quicker and quicker and quicker going
because it's supposed to be hard and the
journey never ends it's just how quick
can you bring yourself back to a place
of receptivity
and interiority where you're like what's
my part in this
and my saying this last year has been
oh well that's been my coping mechanism
it used to be try harder maybe you can
relate to that one yes but then this
year was like hmm this one this happened
or this one oh well
oh well yeah oh well
that's great you ever have little
mantras or anything like that that sort
of you have from time to time that like
pull you through
i do especially like when i'm running
long distance which is extremely hard
for me
um i have like i have different mantras
there i'm just like nah i'm powerful i'm
peaceful you know i'm just like yeah
i just stay relaxed and strong at the
same time but yeah do you feel like
through a lot of these lessons do you
feel like some anything's changed like
sometimes your perception on yourself or
your perception on even the work that
you do the world itself like are there
some fundamentals that have really
shifted for you something happened
recently in my like i'm just clear
that
in certain relationships whether it be
business or friends or
or
intimate
i'm setting my standards
for what i want and what my vision and
my values are in that relationship
sooner
so that it's not unclear so it's like a
boundary yeah boundary
and
and i make sure that the other person is
in alignment and hears it and
understands it
not that i'm like okay if you don't do
this then we're not friends or whatever
but just like this is what i'm looking
for this is what i'm creating this is
what i'm up to this is my values my
vision
and so if someone is crossing that
um
i'm much quicker to just be like okay
this person is not in alignment with
what i'm creating or what our business
is creating or my intimate relationship
and so my my like
my girlfriend now is
it's just clear on my values and my
vision because i'm clear
and i'm clear on what hers are and so
we accept those values and vision and we
don't cross boundaries or if i did
uh you know i take responsibility and i
would and work to improve it but
if someone else is doing that in front
of me
i'm just much quicker to
say okay
is this something that was intentional
or unintentional
and i'm resetting the standard right now
and if this is not something you're
aligned to then cool we don't need to be
in this type of relationship right now
or or i can pull back on certain things
and it's just been a lot clearer for me
as before i think i was always trying to
keep the peace sure and and say okay
it's a it's okay i'll let it pass and no
big deal and then it just happens again
it's okay it's okay and me being more
and more frustrated and resentful with
actually creating the boundary and and
actually standing up to
that boundary so it's been um it's been
an insightful year of creating that in
friendships relationships everything
yeah business work relationship so how
did that i mean
how do you do that tell me what the
process was like to
get to the point where you even knew
what the hell your boundary was like how
do you even how do you even know
um i have i have my values listed out
you know from my business but they're
written
yeah i have my values for my business i
have that everyone sees and and
it's on our job postings here are our
values we communicate it in the
interview process we talk about it on
team calls on a monthly basis hey let's
go over our values just so people are
constantly reminded
um and then you know there are certain
times we need to make examples of like
okay this person
crossed a boundary and it's not okay
with us in our business so we had to let
this person go
and as opposed to what i used to do
which was be
frustrated and
hurt and you know resentful or anxious
around it
it's more like okay i had a moment that
this sucks someone crossed a boundary
and
it was a pretty bad boundary and i was
just like okay this sucks
and i was like
do we give them another chance or is
this something that just doesn't align
like it's so
you know out there that it's like you
can't come back from this yeah and i was
like my old self would have said
uh let's just tell them like you know i
can't do this again it's you know and
give them another chance but this was a
complete cross of a boundary it wasn't a
mixed thing it was a complete cross
and i just said listen i'm not going to
get angry or react this is frustrating
and it's upsetting
but we need to let this person go within
the next 24 hours like there's i don't
care what it takes we got gotta let this
person go there's no trust anymore
it's a complete cross of a boundary and
um
and i'm not i'm not here to react i'm
not gonna get mad it's it sucks it is
what it is we invest in this person it
was time and energy but
it's not a good cultural fit with our
values and
that happened this week
and i remember being like home yeah
it still sucked it still was like had
some energy in my chest but i was like
i didn't need to react i didn't get
frustrated i didn't like text this
person an angry thought i was just like
okay let's just move on and get back
towards our vision
as opposed to focusing on something that
happened in a bad way it's just like
what can we do to move forward so
that's what i'm practicing now as
opposed to allowing things to keep
you know that's crossing the boundary
how did it feel after
for me it felt great um which i've never
done it before so for me i i give i see
the masterpiece in people i want to give
them every chance possible
but this was a clear it was clear to me
it wasn't a gray area it was clear yeah
i said okay i need to do this for myself
and
and for our team to protect our team
from someone doing this because we can't
allow people to do these certain things
that that happen so
for me it was
it just became clearer because
i
think that i continue to do the work for
myself
that i'm able to recognize it better
yeah and that that awareness and
recognition reaction gives me clarity to
take action
yeah i've experienced that myself too
and just in business and just actually
in relationships too i just never
listened um and
um but you know you have you have this
sort of feeling at some point where
you're just like i don't know about this
and you know what
it doesn't really get any better it
really doesn't get any better yeah no
like that's the sk that's the bummer
about it all it's like rarely do things
really get better i mean
i'd love to i i do believe people can
change i just don't think that
i think human nature is to do the
minimum unless they get you know that's
why people have to hit rock bottoms
because you know it takes something like
that to transform it's not like oh you
know you work here you know there's a
really terrible mistake and does it go
completely against our fundamentals and
our values but we're going to give
another chance that's like exactly
that's not really a rock bottom for
someone that's like
and so a lot of times the change takes
place in like deep alchemy and like
really and painful things and so i don't
know that's my that's my own sense about
it is it it tends to not get better
usually whether it's a relationship or
a partnership or work situation and what
i've realized is that
you can't really pull people up they
have to want to come up right 100
you're not going to be able to change
you can't change someone they need to
want to change themselves and be
motivated by something greater
and then you could support them and help
elevate them and be
and be an accountability friend or
partner or leader for them
but you can't push people to want to
grow they need to want it from within
yeah gosh i was just listening to a joe
rogan podcast with a couple of guys and
they were talking about just like the
state of the world and
um
you know the the one thing that was hit
on in it that resonated the most with me
was just that it's you know they're
trying to come up with some solution to
the world's problems which essentially
is outside of you and the one that makes
the most sense and that that was that
was brought forward was just
you know people have to change and it's
like i mean if every it's like you know
if you kind of list look into this
utopian sort of through this utopian
lens if everyone decided to just like
live in integrity and be true and honest
and and and and and live from their
heart and be kind
like immediately everything just changes
everything changes but that takes
everyone doing that and accountability
and
um and that that that that truly i think
is the most important thing that we can
all learn for ourselves is
accountability it's like my therapist
said to me last year the most important
sentence she ever said because i was in
the middle of blaming everyone for
things
especially my parents and she's like no
one holds the keys for you and i was
like oh [ __ ]
and i cried because i was like that's a
lot of responsibility and she's like
well you don't have to do it alone but
you know it is the process and um
and so how do you like you know you're
you have a you have a huge voice you
have a huge platform you're a you're a
leader like what do you feel is your
role in that in that
scope of awareness that that that the
self is the most important like what
what is it that you're trying to do
what are you trying to tell people oh
man i think you said it the keys are
within you
and and i think a lot of us are just
still distracted all day long that we
don't take time to listen
to hear what those keys are inside of us
you know that intuition there's a reason
why something feels off in your chest or
your throat or your stomach
because something is off so it's time to
listen to see what that is are you off
is something else off in your life
are you out of integrity of someone else
like what can you do to realign to
your your greater authentic self and i
think
i personally
try to be the best example i can be at
this season of my life
i
tell people on my show all about the
mistakes and the challenges and the
insecurities that i've worked over
common face just like you do
and i think there's not a lot of um
or at least i should say i don't see a
lot of examples of man talking about
like i did a year of therapy and i'm
healing him and i've got a photo of my
five-year-old self on my phone and i'm
yeah
i don't i don't hear a lot of men
talking like that
not saying i'm better than or you know
more emotionally involved or something i
just think
i'm doing my best to be an example to
show other men that it's okay
and other women that it's also okay to
be with men
who
want to do that because i think
what i've learned
from my personal experience of writing
the mask in masculinity
going on tour talking about these topics
of kind of
men being more vulnerable men healing
men talking about their emotions men
expressing themselves in vulnerable ways
and sharing their shame which the when i
grew up was not a thing that you were
allowed to do was a boy or a man
it was really looked down looked down
upon and made fun of you know called the
name all the names that you know you're
called to
make you look weak
and um
it's funny i remember in my last
relationship crying one time being like
very vulnerable
and my girlfriend being like
not being able to handle it like she
couldn't handle me crying and she was
like it just looks like you're really
weak
like i know that's the wrong thing to
say but that's how i feel because it's
how i've been conditioned
yeah you know it's how i've been
conditioned that crying so she never
cried right
she didn't cry because she thought it
made you're weak
and i was just like well i'm gonna keep
open if i feel something i'm gonna i'm
gonna express it
it's not like i was crying all the time
but there was a few moments when we were
going through some tough stuff and i was
just like here's what i'm going through
what i've witnessed
is
a lot of women saying they want their
their male partner to be vulnerable and
and sensitive and
be more
emotionally
uh flexible
and yet
when
the man is finally like okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna reveal this i'm gonna talk
about my shame and i'm gonna allow
myself to cry in front of my my wife or
my girlfriend or whatever my partner
i have heard the men tell me that when i
did that the woman shut down like their
partner shut down they couldn't handle
it they're like well i'm freaking out
right now so i need you to be strong so
i'm just trying to do my best
to express myself that way and to and to
take down the stereotypes that you can't
have a photo of your inner child you
know and and do these things as a as a
guy
uh with a platform so that's what i'm
just trying to do my best and as i
figure it out to live by example you do
an incredible job of that i think thank
you i appreciate you it's the reason why
you know my boyfriend's like he seems
he's a great i've heard great things he
seems like a great guy let's have dinner
with him um because you're willing to go
there and he's a very emotionally
intelligent and aware guy himself so
um what do you think like this is more
of like a curiosity
because
you know depending on who you listen to
or talk to or even what you think i mean
people like jordan peterson and stuff
it's like a man should be a man and
there's other people that talk about
this too but like i do think that
there's a difference between men and
women i think i don't think that they're
all identical but i think there's some
generalities of like um
things that the that you're one is a
little better at than the other
absolutely and that it's not about like
in this game of like equality
and it's not to me about it's about
equality and it's not about like
patriarchy shifts in a matriarchy that's
not what i'm here for i'm here for this
this sort of
um
opportunity where we each shine in our
own ways which might mean more than the
other in some ways
but
looking at each other
across
genders or roles
with gratitude and respect
that no matter what that is it doesn't
it's not better or worse and that we all
need what we're good at and when we can
embrace what we're each good at then we
become
a better version of the human race
becomes a better version of itself
it's no longer it's not not in a
contraction mode it's in an expansion
mode so what is it i'm curious what is
it that you think
a role is for men that you you believe
in your heart and and perhaps even for a
woman what you think a woman does the
best at or is really shines at when we
figure out what our vision is
and what our goals are
then we can figure out how to get there
easier when we are unclear on what a
vision is for our life
then it's going to be unclear on what
our roles and responsibilities are from
my experience i speak from an athletic
background point of view mostly in team
sports you're more of an individual
sport although you had a team
you know working with you but you were
the the driver in the car there wasn't
like five people in the car you know
doing that but you had a team
and i think a basketball
you know it's like
it's five guys on a court and i'm not
going to go up against shaquille o'neal
because that's not my role i'm not a
seven foot you know beast that can take
him on uh at a center position
my role would be more of a shooting
guard because of my uniqueness my skills
my talents my physicality all those
things
and if i and if our object of
me playing basketball on a team was to
win the championship that was the vision
we're here to play
we're here to win
this game
not saying that you need to win or lose
in life but for the for the context of
this story
you're going to put your teammates in
the best position in the best roles
possible in order to go go up against
the challenges of life yeah whatever the
challenges of that other team you're
playing against or the challenges of
life that you're going up against as a
partnership in a relationship
the thing that i love about my
my girlfriend martha
is that she has a model of
uh her parents have been married for 40
years and
unless they're fooling all of us they
seem like they're incredibly in love
they
are joking and are playful and loving
and you're kind to one another they're
not you know passive aggressive and
angry and dismissive there's this
but she
her mother has a specific role that she
plays in the relationship that she loves
to play that role because she's
more talented more skilled and a better
fit for
than her her husband her husband plays a
different role that has his unique skill
sets his unique talents
that line up and partner up in a
powerful way
where they respect each of their roles
just like i would respect someone like
shaquille o'neal on my team i couldn't
act like i could have those skills
because i don't
i'm not that skilled type of a player in
basketball i have a different talents
and hopefully he would be able to
respect my skill set on a basketball
court
and in my relationship she loves the
skill set and the rest the uh the role
that i play
in our relationship in my life in my
business and in our relationship and she
loves the role she plays
in our partnership as well because we
have come together when we started
dating
and i said this is what i want this is
my vision for my life
this is what i see my life becoming in
the future this is where
this is everything i did in my past
where i messed up and made mistakes
i'm going to reveal everything to you
this is where i'm at now and this is
where i'm heading in the future i'm very
clear on my vision
for my relationship future
what i want based on this season of life
and she said this is what i want and
here are my values my vision we did
exercises we went to sedona and i said
let's do an exercise where you write on
a piece of paper all your values
everything that matters to you
i'm going to write you know on my pieces
of paper in my journal all the things
that matter to me and then we're going
to come unbiased together and see if
they match up about 90 of them matched
up from the things we wanted to do
you know how we wanted to live our life
our lifestyle like all these different
things
and the things that didn't line up i go
are these deal breakers for us sure is
this a super important for you
and you need to have this and if i don't
care about that are you okay with it and
there were no deal breakers in terms of
the whatever 10 of things that
weren't on the same they were very
similar to what we had already talked
about so i said even with that we
we still may not work out you know even
though our values are lined up and our
vision seems to be lined up
time will tell over time if we can
play well as a team
just like in basketball you got to play
well as teammates in order to see if you
can accomplish the goals you have for
that season
and so um
and that takes in my opinion i use
everything in sports analogies
having a great coach and me having a
great coach of my mind and my emotions
and my health and her having a great
coach of her mind her emotions and her
health where we are both accountable
to our
work ethic our energy our attitude on a
basketball team
i've been on teams where some of the
guys are incredible freaks of nature
talented beyond belief could jump out of
the gym dunk shoot run so fast
way better athletes than me but had
horrible work ethic horrible attitude
and
didn't
work together as a team they were
selfish they wanted these things
so they went from starters to on the
bench to being a distraction on the
bench to being kicked off the team even
though they were the best athlete on the
team let that be a lesson so
you've got to be willing to
if you're if you're going to be in a
relationship from you're talking to a
guy who's
failed at every relationship because
they've all ended
and has learned because i chose these
certain relationships and and
and didn't step up to my boundaries and
i kept trying when it wasn't the right
fit
because i didn't communicate my values
and my vision early on and i stayed in
for the wrong reasons so i take full
responsibility
now with that wisdom and that clarity
it's it's easier for me to see it
looking back
because i've gone through that much pain
and frustration for myself
but it's because i have a coach a
therapist
who's allowed me to go through multiple
exercises just like you're talking about
and and experience it be like okay well
moving forward what is it that i really
need i need to play my role
my part
and be clear on my values and my vision
and lifestyle and if the other person
isn't aligned
then there's nothing wrong with that
person we're just not the right fit so
don't get committed in the first place
right and that's not vulnerable early
and you're just like look okay
instead of carrying on and abandoning
yourself which is what ends up happening
by going oh you know we'll just see it's
like you kind of went
stepped up to the plate and went okay
i really like you i know six months in
but here are my here is like my
boundaries i did that i did that like
two and a half months yeah i mean that's
amazing yeah here's something you might
lose them and that's that's the game
right you might being okay
exactly and i think i was never okay
with like losing something yeah
and losing the person losing them loving
me and the connection and the friendship
we built because if it doesn't work out
then maybe we won't speak together and i
was always afraid that i wasn't going to
be enough or that i was going to be
alone or that they would be hurt or they
would judge me or they would think i was
a bad guy because i didn't choose them
and so in this relationship was the most
interesting thing i'd ever done
it was a decision i made and um
both we both made and i started
reflecting on all the previous
relationships
there was let's say sexual activity
early in every relationship right and
that sexual activity created
a chemical bond of this feels good and
this great connection and
and there was no conversation about
values or vision or lifestyle
we're having fun this is a great time
we're experiencing life together and
we've got this
chemical bond
and
this time i said listen
there's there's not gonna be any of that
and um we can hang out and
and
we spend when i say there wasn't any of
that i mean my friends are like in shock
especially my guy friends
i'm gonna get vulnerable here but it's
almost three months i spent 40 nights
next to her without without that
activity going on and um
talk about self-discipline for me as
someone who's driven by you know who
wants that a lot sure i was just like
it's not worth it it's not worth it
until i find out like
where this is going and if we are in
alignment on our values and our vision
which you could call
roles and responsibilities towards your
vision in life
and so again
i feel great right right even with all
this happening it doesn't mean like
it's going to be happy forever and ever
it's just the realistic version who
knows who knows what can happen but i
feel the most at peace it feels
incredible and i feel like i'm laying a
foundation
break after brick of possibilities of
something greater
than
doing the things in reverse that i've
always done so it's it's been a
beautiful experience but it was not easy
and i had to break certain habits so
damn that's my thoughts on
roles and relationships and and everyone
is different right it just doesn't mean
that you know there's it doesn't always
have to mean that there's a macro of
each i mean
it's just kind of what is yours and it's
about respecting the other person
because it's when you can't respect the
other person for being amazing at
something it means that you're insecure
yourself
and you need to do some reflecting
absolutely thank you so much for
checking back in i of course love
catching up with you i yeah you know i i
think that you're just an incredible
leader i think you're just such a voice
and as i told you when i first met you
like because of our conversation that we
had i was promoting my book which like
was now almost four years ago and i did
three podcasts and you were one of them
and i was like i really love that format
and you totally were what led me into
being like i think i want to do a
podcast that's great and um so it's
truly like one it's really the most
fulfilling thing i do so um you're
you're leading in more ways than just
more ways than you know i appreciate
that thank you thank you for the good
work and thanks for the insight for the
new book i have no doubt that it'll be
incredibly beneficial for a lot of
people and especially for men who you
know i think need you know could really
can really use a guide like you for sure
who's willing to get into these spaces
these sticky spaces where
culture hasn't always been so um
accepting or understanding maybe sure um
so
thank you i appreciate it i appreciate
it yeah i'm a flawed human being doing
getting feedback all the time trying to
just improve my life so
you're doing it thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button